[موسيقى]
عام مضى على حرب غيرت العالم في مثل هذا
اليوم من العام الماضي حانت ساعه الصفر
لاحدى اكبر الازمات في العصر الحديث فيما
بدا كشراره لحرب عالميه ثالثه امام معسكر
غربي قادته واشنطن لردع قوات الدب الروسيه
ودعم لم ينقطع منذ اليوم الاول لرئيس
اوكرانيا وقواته بالاسلحه والاموال
والعتاد في ظل اصرار قيصر الكرملين على
حسم ما قد بداه رغم خسائره المتفاقمه عام
مضى انتشر فيه مراسلون العربيه على كل
الجبهات ونقلوا لكم الصوره بكل جوانبها في
تغطيه متواصله بدات قبل اطلاق الرصاصه
الاولى واستمرت معكم بكل ملفاتها من
السياسه الى ميادين الحرب وليس انتهاء بما
تركته من اثار على الاقتصاد العالمي على
سلا سل الامداد التي ما ان بدات بالتعافي
من جائحه كورونا حتى ظهرت الحرب التي غيرت
العالم
تغطيهنا مستمره فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من الصعب الاماكن التي تركز فيها القسط
يدعوننا للدخول داخل الملجا
يجب ان نتوجه معهم الى مكان امن
هو ليس اتفاظ في الشارع وانهضاب على محطات
الوقود
تعاطف كبير مع اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
يعض هنا هو رائحه الحرير
هذا مثلا صفاره الانذار اليوم كل ما خرجنا
من وسط العاصمه تزيد حده الاصوات
[موسيقى]
50 مترا بثمانيه والكمال تفصلنا عن مصنع
ازوكستان نحن الان في الطريق الى مدينه
ماريوبل
طبعا من يشاهد هذا المنظر يعتقد انه حريق
لهذه البنايات ولكن لكميه الاستهداف
[موسيقى]